لا فرق بين كبير وصغير في عشق كره القدم
لدى البرازيليين حتى في اداء التفاصيل
كل هذا الازدحام والاهتمام ينصب هنا على
الاسراع في جمع ملصقات اللاعبين في
منتخباتك كاس العالم قطر 2022 عاده يهواها
البرازيليون ويتورثونها جيلا بعد جيل
الرياضه ونتبادل من خلالها التجارب التي
لا تنسوا منها جمع الملصقات يقوم الكبار
قبل الصغار بجمعها ويفكرون في اهميتها
لسنوات طويله القادمه
الى بلدي كره القدم وصلت كره المونديال
ليطلع عليها البرازيليون وضعت هنا في متحف
الكره البرازيليه للمقارنه بينها وبين
احدى اقدم الكرات التي استخدمت في ساو
باولو قبل 100 عام متمنين ان تكون تميمه
حظهم هذه المره
فرصه حقيقيه للفوز بكاس العالم للمره
السادسه
ومتاكدونا انه سيقدم كل ما يمكن للفوز مع
وجود تشكيله ممتازه لديه
اللعبه الاكثر شعبيه في البلاد بدا
مشوارها مع احضار تشارلز ميلر الملقب بابي
كره القدم البرازيليه كرتين معه الى ساو
باولو في حقيبه ظهره ثم تاسيسه اولى الفرق
ليبدا بذلك تاريخ من المجد يتعلمه الصغار
ويطمحون ليكون جزءا منه يوما
عندما اشاهد تاريخ كره القدم وانجازات
نجومها اتمنى ان اصبح يوما ما كذلك ان
اعشق كره القدم وتربيت على حبها
لا ينحصر تاريخ الكره البرازيليه بين
جدران المتاحف وذكريات نجوم اللعبه
واعشاقها فبين ازقه الاحياء البرازيليه
يتواصل اكتشافه مواهب جديده تعلق عليها
الامال لحصد مزيد من الالقاب
صناعه النجوم واكتشاف المواهب يبداان من
هنا بملاعب بسيطه وامكانات محدوده يتم
تدريب اطفال الاحياء البرازيليه لاسيما
الفقيره منها بكل جديه على يد عشاق اللعبه
مهمه تتخطى كونها رياضيه
ده عروت ويلتشينه دي فيكو
على لاعب كره القدم في ظروف صعبه على
ارضيه غير مستويه وبكرات بسيطه وتاقلم على
ذلك وهذا احد اسرار النجاح
فبالعابهم البسيطه ايضا وفي كل زوايا
حياتهم تحضر كره القدم عند البرازيليين
خصوصا في احياء كهذه تكاد تشكر فيها ملاعب
رياضتهم المفضله المساحه الاوسع لهم وسط
كل الضيق الذي يعيشونه
حسن مسعود الجزيره سوف اولو